hier vous parler du racisme et des
people qui était qui en étaient victimes
et notamment de cette jeune fille qui
s'était noyé site visage avant de se
maquiller de s'habiller comme la
chanteuse aya nakamura pour limiter dans
une vidéo alors ce soir elle est avec
nous elle a souhaité venir sur le
plateau pour s'expliquer donc je pense
que tu es déjà courageux de sa part et
j'ai envie de dire déjà bravo elle elle
va s'expliquer mais avant tout ça va
vous faire un petit récapitulatif de
l'histoire regarde elle est la nouvelle
star de la chanson française avec ses
cheveux bleus et son tube djadja en 2018
aya nakamura fait danser la france
entière cette semaine la jeune chanteuse
a été victime d'un acte raciste sur les
réseaux sociaux elle n'a pas hésité à le
dénoncer rapidement en publiant sur sa
page la vidéo en question
cette personne est déguisé en moi
d'après elle une vidéo qui se voulait
humoristique mais qui n'a pas été du
goût diana camorra en france le black
facing est un acte jugé raciste par de
nombreuses personnes
le fait de se maquiller en noir
lorsqu'on a la peau blanche rappellent
une pratique utilisée au début du siècle
dernier pour se moquer des personnes
noires et cette nouvelle polémique n'a
pas manqué de faire réagir les
internautes
aya nakamura elle-même art posté un
tweet pour le moins explicites sur ce
qu'elle pense de cette affaire des
réactions également unanimes sur twitter
qui est la plus raciste de mes copines
allez on boycotte honteux elle a rien
dans la tête ce débile
il ya assez de racisme comme ça pour en
rajouter bref une nouvelle affaire qui
rappelle à ceux qui l'avaient oublié que
même sur les réseaux sociaux tout n'est
pas permis
ce soir l'auteur de cette vidéo
polémique et répond à et un haka mourra
alors c'est wafa qui va venir nous
rejoindre dans un instant alors elle va
venir sur le plateau pour donc
s'expliquer que vous en pensez vous au
chimène badi je n'étais pas au courant
je viens de l'hapoel way et parce que
c'est vrai qu'avec un mois elle a été
assez choqués par cette vidéo en fin de
séance ouais alors elle l'a mal pris et
moi je pense qu'à partir du moment où la
personne visée le prend mal ça devient
mct aux racistes je n'ai pas terminé
bon allez c'est la jeune femme est
raciste se grimer vous savez ce que ça
veut dire
à l'époque où on paie des acteurs en
amérique qu'il grimé en noir pour faire
rire d audience blanche à des noirs qui
regardent la 11e journée
pas d'accord nous est envoyée sous ça
vous pouvez pas comparer salam
c'est très choquant de voir ça il faut
pas le faire c'est tout ça veut pas dire
et john o'shea raciste là pour le coup
c'était un acteur a fauché ce cas ce qui
choque le plus c'est justement la
radicalisation des jugements à
l'emporte-pièce et ils médias
d'aujourd'hui c'est pas parce qu'on fait
on comprend l'action afrique era black
tête qu'on est rationnel c'est pas par
une blague sur les juifs qu'on est
antisémite mais l'art est refait le mac
sur les femmes
on est homophobe c'est pas une parce
qu'on fait une blague sur les rails d'un
conte et de larmes aux phoques voilà ça
mais c'est comme ça il faut arrêter
juger les gens sur une apparence gérad
raciste qui sont des maisons anodin qui
donne un but comme ça on ne reconnaît
pas c'est parce que tu sais un truc
comme ça que tu es raciste faut arrêter
de juger des gens comme ça alors
wafa est avec nous alors est venu à
s'expliquer applaudissements powa fac et
technique
[Musique]
nous
[Applaudissements]
alors alors alors merci c'est vrai que
les tabous et sans décoller
l'échafaudage marche
il veut agir mathieu d'abord oui parce
que jack avec jean michel c'est
exactement ça désir ridicule et je
trouve que la réaction aussi de aya
nakamura est ridicule aussi décidément
la peau à chaque fois je parle des bons
gars et je suis la bm moi demain je suis
désolé si on revient aussi on ramène ça
à l'homophobie
il ya la vraie homophobie ceux qui
tapent et tout ça quelqu'un qui demain
fera une vidéo en rigolant un peu en
faisant un peu de ghetto ça ça me ferait
rire c'est pas non plus le mot phobie ya
un moment tomber dans l'extrême ça
devient grotesque et joue que sa
réaction elle est idiote parce qu'il y
avait rien de raciste là dedans elle
maladresse tout au plus cette étude va
s'expliquer cette bien ridicule alors
wafa est-ce qu'il faut brancher une
micro doigt face aux p alors ouais enfin
vous voulez vous expliquer soir donc
allez-y vous ai dit je vois là je
voudrais vous m'expliquer en une minute
sur voilà ce qui s'est passé ah oui
effectivement parce que j'ai été
insultée de racistes sur les réseaux
sociaux est effectivement merci jean
michel parce que je suis pas du tout
raciste je suis je m'appelle wafa celle
de l'afrique du nord
donc ce que j'ai fait sur aia la camorra
c'est que la chanson me plaisait
énormément
j'adore ayala exactement donc sur mes
réseaux voilà je suis un peu l'ironie je
rigole japhet j'ai repris la chanson de
soul king dalida donc je vois là je me
suis remis en dalida mais ce que c'était
compliqué pour moi de refaire sur le
king l'a malheureusement j'ai fait un
blackface effectivement il ya des gens
qui ont dit ça les a blessés ça je
comprends totalement donc effectivement
pour ces personnes là je m'en excuse
c'était pas mon cas moi ce que je
voulais faire c'était à refaire et
nakamura tout simplement pour moi
refaire quelqu'un blacks pour moi
personnellement je suis pas raciste
pour moi c'est ce temps de la peau en
noir maintenant je suis pas absolument
pas raciste comme demain si j'ai envie
de faire je sais pas un acteur ou un
chanteur chinois je vais me brider un
petit peu les yeux mais ça veut pas
forcément dire que je suis raciste
envers les les chinois c'est de la
caricature rapidement d'accord alors
mais mais mais vous comprenez que ça
puisse blesser certaines personnes aient
rien nakamura toile a été blessé c'est
pourquoi elle a été blessée
voilà parce que parce que c'est expliqué
lui alors à quoi bon jour wafa oui un
jour on va second bien entendu vous
n'êtes pas raciste mais ce que vous avez
fait est rare
ea store c'est raciste parce que c'est
de la discrimination alors ce n'est pas
illégal en france n'a jamais été
condamné les actions judiciaires n'ont
pas été au bout saleh aux états unis
mais c'est de la caricature qu'on
appelle caricature violente c'est
blessant pour les noirs ça rappelle
effectivement une période où ils étaient
discriminés donc vous ne pouvez pas
faire ça je suis pas d'accord avec jean
michel et mathieu si vous avez fait là
le black fait c'est raciste